philip kumar one of india's best-known
actors has died at the age of 98.
kumar had been acting since the 1940s
and was known as the tragedy king
because of the serious roles he tended
to play
guys she was a filmmaker
he repeatedly missed out on
international fame after turning down
the chance to play sheriff ali in david
lean's 1962 classic
lawrence of arabia film in 1994
india's president awarded him the
highest honor for contributions to
indian cinema prime minister narendra
modi described him as
a cinematic legend
well joining me now is skye's uh neville
lazarus
who is in delhi for us this afternoon
neville lazarus
a massive figure who lived a long life
and
pretty dominant in in bollywood and
indian film for a very long time
it's absolutely true adam and not only
in india but he received the nishani
infjs which is pakistan's highest
civilian order the only indian to
receive it so he transcended both
countries this is also because he was
born in peshawar
in pakistan 1922 and
as muhammad yusuf khan when he started
his filming
his acting career he changed his name to
dilip kumar in 1944 when he did his
first film
he dominated india cinema since then
for over five decades and doing
over 65 films some of some of it
absolute
classics which are still running and
still are box office hits
he has been a legendary cinematic
legendary
legend out here in india in this
absolute film
crazy country with over a thousand
thousand films
produced every year most of it from
bollywood
he has been ill for a few years with
kidney ailments and pneumonia over the
last
few months he's been in and out of
hospital just on monday his wife sarah
banu another actress
of the 60s and 70s in india tweeted that
he is getting better and asked his fans
to pray for him to
to get out of hospital soon but
unfortunately we learned of his death
early this morning he
there's been condolences and tributes
from all
sections of society from all corners of
the country the president the prime
minister actors
sportsmen everyone have have paid their
tributes and respect to this absolute
legendary actor of india